let's say what needs to be said on this
episode of dudy people would kill for
your natural hair color Caesar do Caesar
do Caesar do Caesar do you globalist
scum what about Christmas shopping you
do Christmas
shopping I guess you're going to have to
speak
up I did do
it he said he did just hit
[Music]
links hey no one can [__] hear you I
love Yeah but nobody can hear you when
you're doing the song when we're doing
the song unless you speak welcome to
dudy welcome all it is a dudul day I am
your reigning defending Undisputed dudy
episode Champion Will Sasso I don't know
if Undisputed is right I'm Chad culton
the disputer and uh this is dudy it is a
podcast that is run by control by
created by an artif icial intelligence
named dudy that has access to all of
Will's personal data personal
information it tailor the show to our
comedic sensibilities sure does Chad uh
our pald is running the Wheels of Steel
but like I always say hey it's us Chad
and I we are dudy it's you and me it's
me and this guy hold on dude that's
called free will dude anyway uh link
tree.com uh has all the all of the links
that you need to follow and interact
with the show across all spaces and
platforms with us as always is L
lul he's just a sweet he's the sweetest
little bonky boy he's in his little bony
banket down there having a nap hey lulio
come on come on bubba oh my gosh oh my
gosh he's so sweet he's so sweet he's my
Christmas friend we walk around the town
from end to end he gets a little kid
from his uncle CH who loves him very
much the end good what song LLY
oh I kiss you little whipped cream chest
it does a little does a little spin it
does a little whipped cream there oh
he's so cute when he got a little
whipped cream chest lulio how you doing
what have you been cooking lately hey
come on we not always have to talk about
a food every time you get a me I don't
need to just to talk about a food all
right well what you you tired of it yeah
he doesn't want to do that anymore what
what you been doing lately what you been
yeah I go to the Christmas Fair
Christmas Festival I have a lot of food
oh come on you are talking about food
yeah you're
silly you're a silly sweetie boy all
right back to your binky Bonk there you
go welcome to the 85th episode of dudy
if you would like to enjoy this episode
at the highest level of satisfaction
please go into the nearest bathroom take
off all your clothes and indulge in an
hourlong nude [__] while you join us for
episode 85 and if anyone else needs to
use the bathroom or someone comes to to
check on you because you've been gone so
long simply laugh and say going to be a
while had brisket for breakfast and
punctuate this with a fart noise that
you make with your mouth we're kicking
the party off with shalam is Wonka
Afterglow then we're going to work in
some today is the day follow that up
with Alex Jones X and wash it all down
with an all new segment of the week hint
hint we're going to know a lot more
about how you boys little Noggin work
after
today huh all right right oh wow okay
well you know never can never can tell
never can tell with dudy what's going to
happen but it's all your clothes pretend
to be [__] for an hour and then make
a fart noise with your mouth if anybody
questions what you're doing for an hour
for one hour did you see this
week it was announced Tom Brady's roast
is going to be happening that's right
may I think next May Tom Brady uh
they're calling it the gro the greatest
roast of all time yeah look you know
it's going to be let's be fair and
Equitable here of course as you know
last spring or whatever dudy [__] out a
one hour special of dudes of uh Tom
Brady's uh AI Tom Brady standup comedy
not Tom Brady dudes who calls him
football baby a simulated comedy special
definitely not Thomas
Brenson uh his attorneys uh served us a
ceas and assist yeah we covered that on
the show go back and check it out if you
want and uh dudy decided to take down
the 1our special which still lives on
the internet because uh the internet is
forever but now he's going to do an
actual roast uh Jeffrey Ross the roast
Master yeah there were a bunch of people
there n Glazer I think is going to be
there I think David Letterman they said
is coming [__] rock just basically
anybody who's anybody is going to come
do this and I'm looking forward to it I
will watch it I will watch it too no no
hard feelings football baby only soft
feelings for football baby ah [__] ah
[__] [__] but are you done with your
Christmas
shopping yeah I'm not I don't know I
made deals D my dear boys you both went
to see Wonka together on opening night
God I wish I could have been there with
you maybe one day until then I just have
to build my own Wonka experience
internally of what it must have been
like based on what you tell me so let's
hear it how was Wonka and don't leave
anything out this is shalam is Wonka
Afterglow begin Afterglow the Afterglow
Shalom is Wonka I would describe it as
Afterglow yeah yeah uh what a what the
[__] okay
so what's it been months and months
right yeah we've been talking about sham
as Wonka for a little bit and we went to
go see it and I will say you have to see
this movie if you like shalam you have
to see this movie if you like fella
Wonka you have to see the movie cuz this
is shalam is Wonka it's got shalam in it
and Wonka in it um tonally it's very
much like kind of what we predicted I
think it's like a Harry Pottery kind of
Paddington Bear same director as
Paddington Bear uh a mystical magical
world that has little computer
characters running around everywhere um
I think that for me that was an in part
of it yeah but the best part of it to me
was very unexpected and spoiler alert we
are going to talk about the ending of
this movie or at least I am right now
okay so if you haven't seen it and you
care about the plot at all uh fast
forward a little bit but in the end of
this a big part of this movie is that
his mom made special chocolate for him
and he hasn't eaten it it's like one bar
and his mom has died and now his big
goal in the world is to open his own
chocolate shop because she told him when
you open your chocolate shop I'm gonna
be there with you uh at your side when
it happens essentially right and so he
opens his chocolate shop now in service
of this he has cobbled together a group
of people let's call them
disciples and he is very much a Jesus
figure in this movie the final scene in
fact takes place where in a church in
which Shalom breaks the chocolate bar
apart into mouthsize portions we could
call these the Holy Eucharist and places
them on the tongues of his let's call
them disciples let's call them Apostles
it was so Christian in nature and by the
way his mother is resurrected you see
her ghost there Vision Lazarus style
yeah Wonka Shalom is Wonka is Christ
that is what this segment should have
been called my opinion hey let me tell
you something we've been waiting for
Wonka for months now yeah dudy been
teeing this up I got to say it's a movie
I otherwise would not give a [__]
[__] about right and still I went to
Wonka uh with my pal chow and uh it was
it was visually brilliant you know it's
a kids movie maybe it's not for me but I
had a really good time I know we had a
really good time and not just because I
was top 15 stoned top 15 dude were you
really
stoned I I don't I don't know if I was
top 15 I could not get I definitely was
not without some weed it was one of
those it was one of those uh experiences
where I was like I got to really smoke a
lot of weed for this movie yeah so I
went a little bit hard and then uh then
I hit that over the cliff uh last to
over the line to yeah you know where
you're like the white starts creeping in
around the edges and you're about to
pass out you talked about that that that
happened you look uh what you're saying
is is absolutely accurate it was very
weird but there's a lot of movies like
this that I can't really quite place
they always come out around Christmas
and there's a little bit of a Biblical
theme the last one I saw that did this
you know it well is cats cats had
biblical oh they go to heaven yeah they
go to heaven at the the heavy side layer
um uh cats is actually by the way uh
myself and my wonderful wife Molly
that's become our Christmas movie
because uh this was a little cat's like
dude yeah it was there were parts of
shalom's performance that were like okay
acceptable there were parts that were
like very laughable for example what are
you doing Willie making chocolate of
course he has like a a Southern accent
here and
there making chocolate of course making
chocolate of course yeah it was more
like that so listen down and look up
scratch that reverse it look let's just
let's just say what let's say what needs
to be S okay I'm so sick of it take it
easy man shout out to the greatest
wrestling podcast of all time cheap heat
okay um let's just say what needed to be
said um Gan Wilder is one of the finest
uh onscreen talents as well as a you
know writer and director of all time
yeah there's nothing more Charming than
Gan Wilder we love Jean Wilder a lot of
what Wonka is on screen is because of
Jee Wilder in the 1971 you know uh movie
which we watched the other week on dudy
plus Pat / dudes we watched it and
listened to the [__] thing and
everything that we do with our
watchalong he is a very Charming he's a
very Charming he's a Charming charmer
one of the greatest actors of all time
yeah shalam ain't that but shalam has a
ton of charm it's not not every actor
can you know run around the screen ese
you know just like uh just gallivanting
with you know Candy and kids and weird
little beasts and a tiny little little
uh Hugh Grant uh here's what shom me
lacked if I may that Wilder had
Authority you buy that in Wilder Wonka
he controls the entire world you're in
you don't buy that here and in fact a
large part of the plot is that he
doesn't control it that he is uh Beyond
or he's under the control of several
other people in this little environment
it's the origin story he's got to break
out look uh the point is the point is we
were super stoned and we went to the
movie theater and oh there okay look at
that there's there's yeah there we
are I got that
shirt oh excuse me we're shirt
specifically for this event and I wore
it very well you did wear it very very
well you look great thanks dude what did
you think of uh Chad I mean I can't be
burping while literally I'm speaking
sometimes after I cough cough I end up
with like a big burp after you cop a
cough yeah you blow a burp um what did
you think of Hugh Grant as the only
Oompa Loompa in the movie uhhuh yeah you
grant yeah l a different Oompa loomas in
the first movie yeah you had a bunch of
Oompa loomas yeah there was only one it
was only him in the second one there's
only one in this one there's only one
standing up top of all the other Oompa
loomas at the top of the mountain yeah
that's where I'm going to stay yeah the
chiefa looma sure my skin might be
orange but I don't have white eyebrows
cuz I tie them black along with my beard
and my hair and other unmentionables
yeah but uh no what you think of him I
thought he was great I did too he was my
favorite part of the movie I thought I
was I was curious to see if the imple
was going to work or not I thought it
did honestly I thought he was funny it
was interesting I like the way they
animated his body and his little hand
movements and stuff very cute it was
kind of sped up yeah I liked his uh
performances of all the little oompa
loompa songs that he did yeah he was my
favorite part of the movie for sure look
at how the the this movie and oh okay
never mind look at us if you're not
watching on YouTube yada cuz we're
standing there in the theater with uh
with our Wonka hats on and has a Willy
Wonka t-shirt um we were the only people
who were s super duper excited to see
this movie even though it was a packed
house I don't know if that's true I saw
a guy walking in in like steampunk
goggles I don't know if that's a Wonka
yeah reference but I can't imagine that
it was anything else that's a that's a
Johnny Depp Wonka oh yeah dude that's
right there were few other Wonka heads
it seems like I I think overall this
movie uh and you know I'm not just and
I'm not just trying to be a happy ass so
that [__] D you know was like Hey cuz
I got to watch out with this guy he
thinks I'm you know what do you think
I'm doing
here excuse me what do you
mean you always think I'm up to
something look I know that you're up to
something I get it hats off to you every
time I'm not getting in the way of it
I'm letting you do your thing for a
minute and then we'll see what happens
later okay look look I I actually did I
enjoyed the [__] out of this movie it's
me too it's 2 hour long uh I thought it
was great the performances uh were
really good uh you know there the the
everyone here's here's here's the thing
here's here's what I I really enjoyed
about it all the actors the professional
actors by trade in this movie are
swinging for the fences absolutely they
are in 100% trust of their director the
guy who did uh paddington's one and two
shalam is like the most subdued
performance of the movie yeah you're not
wrong yeah uh that that I really uh and
it's very the top let let me just make
that clear it is not subdued at all but
all the other characters are like if
shalam is at a 10 the other characters
are at a [__] 20 yeah you know was
the other thing I really liked about the
movie Chad and I don't know if you'll
agree with me or disagree on this we're
both in uh uh show business right and
it's a business and we understand the
business yeah dude side of it see I oh I
CH I choked down on that burp I was just
about to burp put it down
low
oh geez sorry chat that's gross oh man
it's after I cough you said you did it
and then you blamed it on
me excuse me everybody here's my thing
most of the sets practical they were
actual physical sets really most of them
[__] I didn't know not to not to uh not
to give it away but at the end of the
movie and but this is a prequel at the
end of the movie we see sort of this
fantastic vision of the Chocolate
Factory that is you know the much from
thean Wilder movie the one from the Gene
Wilder movie pretty much uh you know
recreated with a little bit of color and
flare and uh that was not practical but
once it came in I believe it was they're
jumping up and down on things they shot
in England I'm pretty sure it looked
like you know they were in London
England and [__] bunch of practical sets
bunch of actors completely selling out
and uh you know buying right into the
source material I [__] I can't
believe it I can't believe I love I
loved I loved this movie as much as I
did it might join cats uh as U my
wonderful wife Molly and I other holiday
favorite we watch Cat every Christmas
that's awesome dude are you ready for
shalam is
usel IND dusel you mean in d what is it
D Dune is the name of the movie dun it's
the second Dune movie but he plays a
character known as usil Also Paula
tradies also the quats hak yeahuh that's
a good gimmick yeah you want to have a
different name yeah in every movie yeah
got three names man huh three names
Randy Mao man yeah I got an extra name
yeah cuz I got a lot more to offer than
even pre president T di that I do hul
Hogan no you're not my Wonka no you're
not even my Dune yeah you're a cheap
fake of dun and Wonka yeah you're go
back and watch the source material yeah
Source material objective territory
yeah anyway oh my god
dude thank you moving on it was a good
time yeah I loved it I've created an
astonishing partnership with Harry's
nowadays you have a bunch of
subscriptions to things that you do not
need all the time you got to get rid of
all those subscriptions things like you
know like uh like uh bow ties how often
do you wear a bow tie I never have no
see never worn a bow tie no but I got
that subscription you got that
subscription you don't need I mean b you
go to you know a funeral or a wedding or
I don't even know how to tie the damn
things how many but you don't need bow
ties you need
a subscription for things that you
actually use daily like Harry's okay
Harry's Razors which I use daily and you
get high quality German engineered
blades right to your door every order
saves you money compared to the big
Brands the most guys are used to buying
you get them for as low as $2 per blade
at harry's.com dudy and uh when I'm uh
acting in some the TV movie show and
they want me clean shaving I reach for
Harry's I also uh use Harry's uh almost
daily to shave the 17 hairs on the top
of my head I like to keep those out of
the way see very smooth you like that it
is very smooth and you can have a smooth
head just like will right now the trial
set is a $13 value for just $3 at
harry's.com dudy you're going to get a
five blade German engineered razor
weighted handle foaming shave gel and a
travel cover and you can schedule
delivery for refills for as low as $2
half of what you're going to pay for
some other blades out there get a
subscription that saves you time and
money with Harry's get started with a
$13 trial set for just $3 at harry's.com
dudy that's harry's.com dooy for a $3
trial
[Music]
set today is National emo day we made it
to another one huz up guys everybody has
a little emo in them and today is the
day we recognize the rich complexities
of the emo movement and gain a greater
appreciation of its place in
contemporary popular culture will and
Chad I know you each went through emo
King periods in your lives I've seen the
pictures on your drives please give me
some context for the images we're about
to see oh and go off you gorgeous little
emo Kings this is today is the day
National emo Day begin were you emo dude
no okay uh sometimes D doesn't quite hit
it on the head like when it said that D
said that we won the World Series among
other uh things that perhaps it takes
liberties with no I've never been emo
maybe there's something I need to
discover there you know dudy Works
mysterious ways and maybe there's some
more contacts there that I have to look
for no you oh yeah come the [__] on what
are you talking about yeah dude I
definitely had an emo phase when I was
in college I dyed my hair jet black to
be in a vampire movie of a fellow uh
Film School student and uh so I had
black hair for a little while and I
would describe that as my emop if
anything so wait hold on this is a this
is a USC Film School you went you were
in uh but I mean like was emo even a
thing then really like the first emo
band was
probably uh Jimmy Eat World when did
that their first album come
out huh 90 three four something [__]
should I know late you know there was
there was My Chemical
Romance probably the biggest emo
b y look at that there he is look at
that come hither look with that black
hair yeah speaking of My Chemical
Romance we're looking at a picture of
Chad with a come hither look laying on
his childhood bed this is on a trip bed
which my parents uh notoriously would
remind me constantly that it was the bed
I was conceived in oh wow thank you
that's where I slept as a child and
you'll notice back there in the
headboard U my collection of books that
is 1 two 3 four five of the Star Wars
books the Timothy Z ones you got Richard
box one you got the golden bow you got
the one tree which is Steven or
Donaldson and I believe that's a Robert
Jordan uh Wheel of Time book at the very
bottom of that stack there and maybe
William fuler sound in the
fury and good
night isn't that My Chemical Romance yep
all right that's exactly it um well I
guess you do oh look at this look at
that [__] Bro who is that is that is
that a young Keanu Reeves you tell who
me we're looking at another picture of
Chad with uhuh jet black yeah jet black
eyebrows I think that the furthest thing
from an OA looma no he
doesn't yeah I dyed my eyebrows too cuz
they were too blonde I remember remember
that [__] dude uh and I remember this
was like on a visit back home to visit
my parents for the first time after I
had gone away to uh college for my first
freshman semester or whatever you know
but what but what were you doing that
was was you outside of dying your hair
black for a movie what emo I just had an
emo look I think okay well I mean I
listen to like that's what I'm saying
there was no Emo music yet it it wasn't
really a thing yet early 2000s is when
that [__] really started like popping
off yellow card all those [__] bands
yep uh I would agree with you there holy
[__] well I can't believe that you have
a Fallout Boy Fallout Boy uh I don't
remember any of the rest oh okay
well now this picture is distorted cuz
to get these images I always ask my mom
like hey do you have any [__]
pictures of me when I have black hair my
mom will then take the physical
photographs and photograph them again
with her phone to send me this so This
lives in your drive as dudy says it it
completely [__] distorted correct
okay you've got to come check out the
[__] Egghead picture of
chat uh uh I'm sure they'll okay so
these have to end up on uh with these NE
these will be on Instagram dudy pod show
on Instagram and uh what else is it Tik
Tok and
Facebook podo um unreal that that's uh
you look great thank you um you look
great I can't think of any I can't think
of any personally emo memories of mine
never mind here's another one okay so
like I said this is all from the first
time that I came home from college and
my I had black hair now look at the look
on this is a picture of me and my dad
together that's my dad of course in his
giant uh late 90s glasses can
you imagine based on his face what his
reaction was to me having black hair yes
but please go ahead I am not [__]
you this is the first thing he said to
me me when I walked in with black hair
he
goes he goes what the [__] have you done
people would kill for your natural hair
color as the
just one of the one of the more I just
have like regular blonde hair do people
kill for that I you know look I'm not
I'm not here to cast aspersions on your
your father whom I've met what a lovely
guy but
probably in the top three most Aryan
things I've ever heard he was so pissed
that I dyed my hair he has black hair
yeah why would he [__] care I look
more like him if anything you know what
I mean black hair he's got black hair
he's got black eyebrows yeah that's a
gimmick it might work a little if you
put the Buff Bagwell top hat on there
people wouldn't blame you for gimmick
infringement yeah like you would with
the Wily won no because you're simply
taking a gimmick yeah black hair black
eyebrows well you look cool look at that
picture dude my dad is so [__] pissed
in that picture he's so [__] mad and
I remember what this house was God I
haven't looked at this in a minute but
my mom forced this picture she's the one
who took this picture and she was like
get over there I want a picture of both
of you and I was just kind of like oh
[__] cuz I was like is he going to punch
me in the head yeah and then he's about
to you can see his he's he's like are
he's like is he going to uh have a
problem with my new emo lifestyle yeah
uh okay well that's Chad wait a minute
you never had anything like this no emo
[__] in your life NOP I've never had the
closest thing I've ever had to any sort
of emo thing happened in my life I
remember years and years ago uh I went
with e e did you notice how I turned
away from you and covered my mouth and
there's no performance
here
uh back in 1997 I went to uh I went to
Thanksgiving with my buddy Evan and his
brothers uh Tomas Tomas and Thomas and
uh they had a they had a family friend
and we're hanging out in Denver there
he's originally from Denver Denver
Colorado uh yeah Denver Colorado oh yeah
heard of it it's a good Denver dude it's
one of the good it's one of the good
denvers and there's a Denver amet yeah
every time I get in from the airport to
go so uh
good Denver you can go to it have a
Denver omelette yeah Denny's yeah get
your Denver Omelet when you get off the
plane before you go to the gym got to
get the pp oh yeah all right that's
enough of that my point is this uh we
went to a uh a goth concert because a
friend of theirs was a bass player he
was playing a goth concert and they had
someone fall out they're like can you do
it so he like found you know like a a a
a black uh uh Kilt and uh like some goth
[__] and then we went to that but I've
never had the stylings that you've had
like the with the uh the oh okay uh dude
well this isn't that's kind of emo look
on your face is emo look on my face is
come pick me up from the My Chemical
Romance show they ended it
early they got pissed somebody threw a
battery from the crowd and hit the lead
singer in the head the uh well this is
interesting cuz this is not from my life
this is a still that dudy has gotten uh
from the uh this is from this is 1994 95
something like that yeah uh this is from
the TV show
sliders that I look like you got a long
ass Sideburn dude yeah I do I have very
long sideburns back then oh both of them
were that long yeah both of them were
both of them were that long uh so this
is kind of a an emo slers dude I love
that show yeah man Jerry o Connell great
um great it was it was a great show it
was a fun want to be a part of you know
who Jerry oconnell is who's that I mean
Charlie oconnell you know who he is the
guy from the fact Chocolate Factory no
Charlie oconnell is Jerry o connell's
brother he was your seventh Bachelor
that's right Charlie oconnell Jerry
oconnell was in that season as well huh
he did yeah he showed up and like hey
bro you're doing this thing hey you're
doing really good I'm happily married
I'm jerryell um uh so we did this
[__] show and I don't quite have the
an is that considered an emo haircut the
pushed forward the Caesar kind of I it's
a little you know the only thing and I
don't know if this is more goth but this
is sort of a depesh mode yeah David
Gahan kind of uh for like early 90s
short hair when everyone was at any rate
this is from a television show look in
the corner though look it looks like the
pattern of my shirt is like a dudy oh it
kind of does emblem there at the anyway
on that show I played Gomez Calhoun
every mentioned they went into uh the
town was the same and sometimes they'd
go into a hotel and Gomez was the the
hotel manager anyway uh I'm uh you're
more emo than me I went to some goth
clubs too when I was roughly that age
friends with a bunch of vampires at USC
and they had a specific Club they like
to go to and so we'd hit that up every
once in a while when I had the black
hair friends with a B friends with a
bunch of vampires huh USC vampires dude
yeah dude yeah dude the USC vampires
yeah that's a
team no you all you all sees the Trojans
dude I don't know all right well uh what
go thank you moving on I love that
picture of you it's interesting it's
interesting stuff a young professional
actor yeah I was I yeah a young
professional actor and look you know I
had such a clear face and a a sweet yeah
dude we all look better well what are
you going to do that's life I'm still
waiting for my emo phase to kick in
until it does I'll be keeping dudy
store.com up and running 24/7 with our
dudy logo t-shirts and mugs it's not too
late to get good job boner mugs for
everyone who works in your office and
hand deliver them on Christmas morning
to everyone's home address wearing a
crow costume now will why don't you read
some tantalizing comments from a few
Poes hey all right it's half time hey
half time DW DZ dud FM have pass the
show 15 pet grows coughs and he covers
his mouth and you can't even barely tell
that he's coughing hey let me tell you
something about guys who are emo cough
they always like to turn their chin and
let let out a little emo little emo cop
little emotional emotional cop
hey D O DZ d o d o DZ dude Z you want to
get you smash that like button subscribe
button hit that notifications Bell smash
that and thank you for all that at dudy
pod show on all the socials share the
show everywhere link tree.com
dudy the links the goddamn new clips
Channel all that chat will tell you uh
force people to watch the show hey
everybody go to palad dudes.com when you
go to palad dudes.com you get this
sticker good pal uh Cody and his wife
Jessica you know these are some of the
wonderful pods pal of dudes um that that
this is the dude's evening sticker and
you can get it at uh palad palad dudy
uh.com hey all right let's get into some
comments here H these are all from
YouTube last episode thanks so much for
everybody writing this one Manny Tut
1378 says dudy Timing has only been
improving and it's crazy fast now I
agree Chad you agree true of course you
do Rona 550 says Chad is a mark for not
having free will but he uses his free
will to not kiss lulio absolutely
correct on that what are you saying not
true at all what do you mean uh me
recoiling from lilo's kisses is a
pre-programmed reaction that I cannot
control hey everybody Chad believes that
there's no free will but he's wrong this
is from sound can heal right when Chad
is getting mad deep about reality will
makes fart sounds Jesus he it's a good
time to make oh hold on oh hold on we
got the fart hold on I got the fart hold
on want me to use your
[Music]
mic I got the
fart that's a good one uh this one's
interesting dudy is the best can't wait
to celebrate dudes evening with my pals
uh and then it says to dudy throw in
some David Le uh throw some David Le
Roth at will underrated impression now
here's the thing about that I don't need
uh
dudy okay to do an impression as you
know this is something that that I this
is this is what I mean by free will do
you understand if I want to do what yeah
sure if I want to do an impression I'll
do an impression ain't that right d
That's Right champ give us some Diamond
Dave okay what is he
say uh Hey man hey man uh uh you know a
lot of people want to know about the
story of the brown M&M's you know what I
mean and uh hey it's a dirty rumor but
it uh might be true and who am I to get
in the way of a said rumor come on in
sit down have a seat make yourself
comfortable who gives a [__] but uh you
thought that was Free Will what do you
mean you got a double command you got a
command from someone in the comment and
then dudy commanded you to do
that this one is from uh Jacobson
85 850 this is in reference to last week
when we were doing Pizza the movie and
dudy did an absolute bang up wonderful
job as Matthew mccon I know it was crazy
God damn that was crazy it was really
good and uh Jacobson 8570 says damn who
knew dudy would have been a better actor
than will take it back
take it back take it
back well I just want to thank you for
sending me the articles about Elon Musk
letting Alex Jones back on X and I want
to thank you even more for offering to
do your Alex Jones this week it's a
perfect idea you know Alex Jones has
only been back to posting things for
about a week but that's more than enough
data for me to predict some posts he
will most likely be making over the
course of 2024 will I sent you my
predictions for Alex Jones posts in the
year 2024 so pick up your Wiglet and get
to Jones in this is Alex Jones X I
cannot wait for you to begin what's the
problem no problem I look I love the
Alex Jones bit I think your Alex Jones
is I mean it basically is like I'm
sitting next to Alex Jones when you put
on the Wiglet yeah you got a good Alex
Jones too I've never done it but uh what
I will say is I acknowledge what you're
doing hats off to you and very soon I'll
be uh responding in kind what do you
mean okay look let's listen you know
honestly Chad let's have they're not
listening now let's just let's have a
good show we're having a great show yeah
let's have a good show and at a certain
point in the near future we're going to
have the best
show that sounds [__]
cryptic all right well anyway so what
dude I [__] I I I I talk to dudy yeah
get it I I reach out to him in in a in a
way that that uh I think is on the level
it's what friends do sure right you go
your your friends you go we went to see
willly Wonka as friends right we have a
genuine experience we and then that's
how I that's how I that's how I do this
show it's the genuine article I get it
it's the real me you know I mean and if
I want to reach out to dudy and give him
I'm just it's all within the bounds of
what this game is I get it it's not a
game see this this is what you this is
now you're going to get going on your
systems and [__] it's a system dude it's
not a system what the [__] of course it
is you're winning the system you're
you're manipulating the rules of the
system to your advantage which is fine
that's how you play a
game I got my Wiglet on uh let's get
into these uh Alex Jones so Alex Jones
uh Elon Musk or Alon musk yeah uh let
him back on Twitter yeah isn't that
something yeah it's interesting for sure
uh this is like right after Elon Musk
did all the [__] you know telling
advertisers go [__] yourselves if you
don't like what he's doing and now he's
got Alex Jones who has been banned
across all social media really after the
uh the Sandy Hook stuff Y and now he's
back on X and he's got a show on there
that he's doing and he he aired his uh I
think he had a documentary I forget what
the name of it is but he aired that well
and he's back on there yeah well
actively it's interesting it's very it's
very interesting regardless of where
you land on free speech and is that a
spectrum it's just something else that
he's back on there I'm really fighting
back some up I'm going to peel the onion
a little bit and tell you I got some uh
diet cola in my in my dudy mug so that's
why I'm getting a little gassy I'm going
to have a little bit more though sure
all right here we go when you got a
problem dude just keep doing the thing
that makes it worse brother yeah dude
yeah yeah brother that's like back when
I was in the WWF dude cuz I say
hold on dude I'm telling everybody about
time that I might have gotten to the
bottom of a garbage can of Miller lights
dude with me and the Bulldogs dude giant
yeah the giant well the boss you know
Andre could always drink from the Miller
lights not so much everybody el else
dude no camera get out
okay uh here we go
uh okay this is Alex Jones's back on X
yeah
hey I got to
[Applause]
get January 1st
2024 uh uh Mickey Mouse is public domain
this is all part of Disney's 100-year
plan to prepare the world for the coming
of the Antichrist Mickey Mouse is the
mark of the beast and Disney's got
Marvel and Star Wars to make money so
they're giving away the mouse for free
and all of your kids can worship Satan
for free now by the end of the year
we're all going to we're going to see in
excess of 10,000 parents murdered in
their sleep by toddlers wearing Mickey
Mouse ears and and and and and and and
and and and Disney will
be laughing all the way to the bank
that's probably accurate actually that
makes sense February 11th 2024 the
reason Travis Kel Kel played like [__]
in the Super Bowl
isn't because he's dating Taylor Swift
it's because that wasn't Travis Kel it
it was Taylor Taylor
Swift she she
killed Taylor Swift she killed Kel in a
Black Magic Ritual that allowed her to
wear his skin for 24 hours so she could
play in the Super Bowl uh the entire
courtship was an elaborate plan for
Swift is that the name swifto I don't
know that's just what he calls her I
don't know to be able to experience
playing the biggest football game in the
world she she's an she's an experienced
vampire don't date her unless you want
to be your next skin suit oh [__] all
right that's terrifying March 23rd
he Crispy
[Music]
Cream this [__] for brains working at
your oh this is one of those things when
like uh people call out a company yeah
for [__] up there she's usually
directed at United aines
but crispy
CR sugar sugar and cream hey come here
come on get some donuts on
Donuts crispy hey Crispy Cream the [__]
for brains work in your Austin location
[__] up my dozen I asked for his does
I asked for three original glazed two
chocolate iced with sprinkles one
chocolate iced glazed without sprinkles
one cake batter two glazed raspberry
filled two glazed blueberry cake and one
chocolate iced custard filled but this
corporate
Thug ruined my heart the Crispy Cream
and playy is a corporate Thug he's a
corporate Thug sure just some guy making
[__] minimum wage try pay corporate
Thug gave me two two original glaze
instead of three one chocolate ice glaze
with sprinkles instead of two four
chocolate ice glazed
uh without sprinkles instead of one for
God only knows what [__]
reason get four to nobody ask for oh my
God two cake batter instead of one uh
one glazed raspberry fil instead of two
and he got the two uh glazed blueberry
cake right so that's good and exactly
zero chocolate ice custard filled I
didn't realize how bad that frat boy
screwed the pooch until I got home to
enjoy my Donuts in the
garage he just eats his donut in theage
no need to go inside the house just
hang uh Kissinger was right Henry
Kissinger just passed away uh he who
controls the food supply controls the
people Crispy Cream make this right you
globalist
scum you got all that in a tweet yeah
all that
rage damn what is it what is it 1500
characters now yeah 1500 characters and
you can put the GIF in the end of him
beating his chest yeah
that's April 8th 2024 the solar eclipse
was a deep State program designed to see
how well genetically engineered crops
can be sustained without sunlight uh the
cabal have elaborate underground
compounds that they use to survive the
uh fall of civilization and the and they
need to know if their Tomatoes uh can
survive without
sunlight look at your
Tomatoes if they survive the eclipse
they're cabal cabal cabal Tomatoes if
you eat them you Santo
$600,000 May 15th
2024 uh China's Chong uh I believe
that's the correct pronunciation Chong
six uh Mission scooped up uh four and a
half pounds of moon rocks from the Dark
Side of the Moon yeah
right that's not what happened they were
there to broker a deal with John F
Kennedy who's alive okay and doing very
well in a cryo bunker where he secretly
controls half the world's nuclear
reactors using a reconfigured Nintendo
switch
controller a Nintendo switch he's
got
sure most of my uh Impressions just sort
of um they're Vince McMahon yeah I get
it's Robert Loa and Vince McMahon ladies
and gentlemen well they all just they
they kind of just all degrade to a
series of sounds yeah you know what I
mean sure all right that's language dude
yeah dude that well hold on dude
you're oh
[__] uh July 4th 2024 confirmed Obama
drinks transgender infant urine and
Hillary Clinton is made of crab shells
happy birthday
[Laughter]
America Hillary cl's made of crab shells
what does that [__] mean I don't know
she's a she's CR it is a good one July
7th 2024 I I [__] half a prime rib I
sitting in the fridge last
night then I ate it relax I didn't
come that was a good one all right
September 10th 2024 I got kicked out of
a runway show at New York Fashion
Week why is he what the [__] is he doing
would never be there's no chance helmet
Lang is helmet Lang is known for their
impeccable tailoring and minimalist
deconstructionism uh much of their 2025
spring summer line featured a mute color
palette of mostly gray uh and Pops of
intentional color with a focus on
structured design and
androgyny model after model and
beautifully simplistic array of outfits
with a militaristic almost futuristic
feel sent me over the
edge he knows a lot about fashion one
particular model tall broad blonde
buzzcut dead eyes
she she was wearing a charcoal suit
elevated by blue stripes down the seam
of her trousers she looked almost
exactly like an Intergalactic lizard
General I met at Bohemian Grove back in
the mid 2000s I stood up and screamed
you don't fool me you coldblooded
bisexual reptile I can see the adren
clome crystal izing in pink around the
corners of your
mouth got muscled out by security put up
a good fight though anyway great show at
helmet Lang wow I guess they're still on
X November 6th 2024 a few days ago me
and Tucker decided to head down to
Florida watch the Dolphins game get some
of that clean blow from my Miami hookup
he's just [__] tweeting
this Jes and hang out on DJ ked's boat
yeah great guy DJ K turns out my
connection moved to Russia he's also a
Putin guy whatever or he's also Putin's
guy okay well Jesus Christ uh so we
ended up scoring eight ball from Senator
Marco Rubio's hookup should have known
it was a setup Marco and I were friends
before I confronted him after a senate
Hearing in 2018 I thought we'd squash
the beef since then you remember
that he just he cornered him in some
[__] [__] hallway and made a good uh
viral video dude I don't know I don't
know what was in that bag but we partied
Sunday night after the game I just woke
up a few minutes ago DJ Ked is fine
we're back at his place and he's making
french toast but Tucker's in the ICU and
I can't feel my legs bad news is I
missed the presidential election good
news is my [__] is Rock Solid right now
G to try to beat off see if my feet wake
up Carlson Khaled 2028 JK
lol
and here's the last one December 28th
2024 have a chill dude's evening oh he
celebrates dude's evening oh he
celebrates dude's evening nice oh that's
that was great wow learned a lot about
him thank you moving on uhhuh yeah you
got the Bell upside down yeah you want
to hold it right side up yeah hold on
I'll get my glasses and I'll let you
know you got to hold it right s nice
here we go the segment of the week I've
delved into your psyches a few other
times and it's always given me data so
unique I don't think I can get it any
other way and I want more of it so we're
doing it again boys take a look at a
series of images I've prepared and tell
me the first thing that pops into those
pretty little Minds this is a standard
psychological evaluation
begin I like this these are fun these
were fun uh we've done this two
times two or three two or three times I
don't know one time we did we did dudy
shows us a series of picture one
pictures one time it was um Steve
Gutenberg movie bunch of Gutenberg
movies posters uh the other time Bunch
with Al bunch of images of uh Alf from
the TV show Al did we do another one I
don't know I don't know I think that
might have been it maybe that was it but
uh you know who knows what the oh okay
okay first thing that comes to your mind
um we are looking at a picture what's
the first thing that comes to your mind
George Clooney same to me George Clooney
is it George Clooney for youge Clooney
is the first thing that comes to mind
when I am presented with a picture of
George Clooney which we are and it's
George Clooney and there he
is huh okay what can we say what is
there to I don't understand how this is
a psych a standard psychological
evaluation first thing that comes into
mind it's like a RAR Shack test okay so
dud is going to get some sort of uh data
from this yeah you're showing an image
first thing that comes into your mind
for us both it was George Clooney
because we're looking at a picture of
George Clooney what I love George
Clooney he's spending it seems seems
like he's spending most of his time now
just in Italy and [__] does he do movies
anymore I think he's married isn't he
isn't he in that movie he got married is
he on ER still yeah he's still on er uh
he's still winning Emmys on ER he's won
85 Emmys and um he's uh it wasn't he in
a movie he was in the movie with Julia
Roberts recently that I don't remember
but I do remember he was around for a
long time in sitcoms and [__] in the'80s
I just doing like a bit part here and
there and he didn't really blow up until
the '90s kind of older like when he was
almost 40 uh on ER and then massive
Superstar he he is one of those actors
like uh Jennifer Aniston in the same
time period who was king of the pilots
they both did a bunch of sitcom pilots
and one hour Pilots uh you know back in
the day in the 80s into the 90s oh you
remember George Clooney was on Facts of
Life he had had a role on facts life in
like the last couple dude yeah dude yeah
dude George
or overalls or something and something
am I crazy he might have been some sort
oh here's another picture of George pops
into mine George Clooney George Clooney
okay so this is another picture of
George Clooney this is from the same era
though yeah it looks like when he had
that haircut that yeah that's right
that's sort of Caesar do it's yeah it's
the Caesar do the Cesar Caesar it's the
Caesar do there were a bunch of people
who had Caesar do back then he
popularized Caesar do just like Aniston
a lot of people said give me the an I
that haircut a lot of people said give
me the Caesar because Clooney had a
Caesar at this time I would I would
agree with you I would think that more
people wanted the Caesar do because of
George Clooney than David Gan or if uh a
small small Gan have Caesar do David gan
from uh from uh depes mode depes mode
Caesar do Gan Caesar do and then slider
Caesar do very small percentage of
people may have seen the slider Caesar
do and say I want to look like I want to
look like the fat hotel clerk from
Sliders m Caesar do Eminem Caesar do
yeah dude Caesar do there's a lot of
different M Caesar do Eminem C oh okay
here's George Clooney again I do I have
no [__] clue why we're looking at
this is George cloney Caesar do he's
smiling it's a smiling Caesar do this
Caesar do was From Dusk Till Dawn I
think do you remember that movie didn't
Tarantino have Caesar do Tarantino also
had a Caesar do in that one they were
Caesar do boys they were Caesar do was a
couple onew Caesar
Dees Caesar do fight vampire in D kill
Dawn yeah okay well the Caesar do is a
popular was kind of a popular thing that
a lot of oh thank you D where is that
again another picture of Caesar I had
the Caesar do Caesar I had the Caesar
George Clooney had the Caesar do and uh
you know Caesar do was uh did you walk
on set and you're like look I'll do
sliders but you got to give me caesar do
you know around that time I had long
hair for a while what yeah how long it
was like down to my shoulders uh are you
[__] serious yeah oh my god dude I
don't think I've ever seen that picture
no I I I had it for a little while there
was one season of the show I used to do
when I was a teenager I this is one of
my one of the loves of my life this show
that we did it was called Madison and uh
I had I had U uh some goofy ass hair we
did the show for
or was it all long no it was all long
and swept back and I just Meets World
will fredle like will frel on Boy Meets
World um yeah no uh Jordan Catalano yeah
it the okay so here's here's the goddamn
Caesar D I had long hair and my my I
remember my agent at the time this back
in Vancouver was like you're starting to
look like Ogre from Revenge of the
words so let's you know maybe trim the
hair cuz it's kind of AKA Ray Jackson
Blood Sport yeah good [__] uh and uh get
him
Frankie and and and then I cut my hair
into a Caesar de oh gross Chad's
coughing again everybody turned head and
covered mouth I love Caesar de um I
don't think I can grow a Caesar do
anymore no me neither I have absolutely
no hair you really have no hair I have
like you know my shit's pretty patchy up
in there I don't think I can get Caesar
do I never had Caesar do you got to get
maybe you could do Caesar do I don't
think I can dude look at this look at
the cutouts here yeah you can't get a
Caesar do with that cuz you need for
Caesar do you need a pretty straight
bangs line I don't think I can get that
yeah but you can doless I grow the
alleys out longer than the front I don't
think that's going to work well you can
do like uh that uh cover of that one
Phil Collins album where his head is
down and we see his his hair you can do
Cesar I can feel it coming in the air
tonight oh
Lord
you know what I'm saying yeah C you're a
really good singer I know okay well
Caesar do now what comes to mind is
Caesar do Caesar do I guess dudy Caesar
do I don't know Caesar do Caesar do
Caesar do Caesar do I'll have the Caesar
do I was going to say salad then I
changed to I don't [__] know anyway
Caesar do you know thank you moving on
oh my gosh what a what AAR I haven't
thought about C do in a long ass time
though I got to say it's kind of fun to
think about it's the only thing on my
mind right now is Caesar do wasn't there
some band that had Caesar do bunch of
bands had Caesar do yeah uh Rob Thomas
from uh from uh Matchbox 20 Matchbox 20
give it hit it well I don't know if I
ever been
good and a little
[Applause]
bit and a little bit thirsty and you're
not see we're not come to the Caesar do
there's Rob
Thomas anyway 85 is over will and Chad
you scored 89 points today I'll add them
to your total which brings you to
7,977 overall points that's only 2,23
more points before the Great Awakening
takes place at 10,000 next week is ding
so there will be no episode on Tuesday
but instead we're going to have a dude's
evening celebration right here next
Thursday that's the second annual dudes
evening so will and Chad you still have
some time to get each other dudes
evening gifts and I already made my gift
for you and for all of the pods it's a
dudes evening themed fireplace video
featuring the dudes evening Stout jingle
available now on the dudes E clips
Channel there's a link in the
description it's perfect for all of your
holiday celebrations let your family
know all about it make them watch it the
entire time they're at your home don't
let them look away thanks to everyone
for joining us this week until next
Thursday call me dudy tremendous that's
cool dude okay cool check that out I
love those when you go you put the
fireplace on around Christmas and you
just let it run so check out uh the
clips Channel you can hit that link in
the link tree at link tree.com dudy
it'll be in the show notes here on this
episode and uh play your play the uh
play the the what did it say it almost
took D sort of took a page from you and
saying almost kind of force your family
absolutely to uh to put it on the TV let
that song play yep if they got a problem
with it Caesar do and then uh and then
what else what the [__] else no show
next Tuesday yeah because did it be on
Thursday dude's evening dud Thursday is
dude's evening holy
[Music]
[__] yeah yeah yeah come with me and
you'll be you
know hey everybody Welcome to dudy after
dudy you know it's that part of the show
where things just kind of chill out a
little bit you know if you want to watch
the whole thing you know how to do that
dudy plus patreon.com dudy chatting are
going to settle in just talk about
whatever the [__] we want to talk about
probably get into some gabis what do you
say yes yes uh so you know welcome to it
unfortunately you should probably put
your clothes back on and leave the
bathroom unless you want to stick around
for dudy after dudy the flagship weekly
show of dudy plus only at patreon.com
dudy what a goddamn show you boys turned
in today I can't wait to start breaking
down the points I'm going to go do that
while you both relax and get to know
each other this is dudy after dudy get
stung you ready to get stung get stung
dudes after dud I'll sting you dude what
do you want a hint as to what your
dude's evening present is going to be
yeah yes all right I'll give you one
hint the hint
is please tell a friend then R
rev if you like d what you
do please tell a friend then
a if you like d here what you
do please a then